people ask you the same questions over  and over and over again what kind of  questions you want people to ask you so  you don't have to answer the same  question  so steve this is literally the question  i hate the most  i'll explain in a minute literally you i  would have preferred you asked me the  same cliche question that i've been yes  i'll tell you why  when you're answering people's questions  you need to provide them value not  yourself value there's nothing i want to  be asked all i want to do is give people  what their question is i don't mind  answering the same question over and  over you know why we have seven to 11  basic themes that are [ __ ] us up  right